X
HIGHAT S SHOCKING DELOT  E HIGH
CEO.
ANNOUNCI DEPARTURE, IT W
SHORT.T SAYS FOXA AND
CK THANK FOR HIS WORK AT T A HO
NTD HIS FINAL
PR
RLSON SAID ON FRIDAY H
LOED
CHL SHOWED A ON  SHOULCKCARLSONE
DISTRUST IN THIO COURSE THIS AN
ST DAYS AFTER X NEWS SETTL THAT
TTLEMENT IHISTORY  EDIA THAT'S .
IT'S HARD TOECE
EVENTS, K AND RLN T CONNECTING .
WE REACHED TN
VEME TODAY, D HOOE NOT REQUESTSR
G WAYSH CH DONN.NNING
ANNOUNCEMENT.
ALLY IN AN
TO CNNEO CHRIS
HE SAINN AND HAVDON WILL FA PAR
FOR HICONTRIBUTIONOVYEARS, AND
MORE EXPLICIT.
E NETWORD
HIM, LASHEAND SAID THAT HE WASII
DILYND
N PR O STATEMENTRATELYING WHAT E
DIHATUNITYO MEET
WITH
SO THERE'S A BACK AND FORTING O
ABOUT C
UNIVERL. TANDOE A SEXUAL
RA ALLEG'SOMG FROMC ANCHOR
CORRESPONDENT HADLY LE
THIS L T ITIUT A STATE  AFTER T,
ION, AND  ULTIMY LETO COMCAST
NBCU'ST COMPAN